the scary decision is telling my boss
telling my wife giving up the salary but
scary only lasts like a few days like
you'll get over telling your boss or
disappointing your college professor
whatever it may be but dangerous is
staying in this job and then when I'm 80
years old looking back and be like damn
I wish I started that Brewery
my favorite quote that I found so far is
if you win the rat race you're still a
rat what does that mean to you
yeah so um I shifted my definition of
success after I read Anna quinlan's
commencement speech and in her
commencement speech she says something
like you know if success looks good good
to the world but does not feel good in
your heart then it is not success at all
is Lily Tomlin says if you win the rat
race you're still a rat it just to me
means like if you've gotten to the top
of the career ladder or the top of your
industry or whatever like cool that's
amazing for that one part of your life
but does that mean that you've lived a
fulfilling life
it depends like how's your personal life
how's your social life whatever
um so to me it's like I was I recognized
in myself that I was playing that game
and I was on that in that rat race and
the next step didn't look that exciting
to me in my traditional media job so I
asked myself like is this it and then I
realized like no like I can I can choose
a different path and I can play a
different game and I don't have to be a
rat
wasn't there something about uh
continuing down the same path would be
true failure but changing and not
succeeding would be more like success
yeah in a way like I see successes
trying many different things and also
like getting a variety of perspectives
rather than just doing this one thing
that you know in some ways like I felt a
little bit of a hypocrite because I was
working at Fortune Magazine covering uh
Tech and venture capital and startups
and I was talking to these entrepreneurs
all day long and I was analyzing their
companies and talking about the
leadership strategy moves they were
making and I was like I myself have
never started anything and I've never
run a business who am I to evaluate
these people like of course there's a
time and place for that
um but I felt like I want to do this
myself
and only then will I feel successful
okay so how do the best performers
Channel their creativity
creativity oh in so many ways um in the
book I talk about how true original
creators have three kind of uh uh
characteristics the first is they have a
unique point of view on the world the
second is that they have this like
audacious ambitious goal they want to
achieve and third is that they're
willing to fail spectacularly in the
name of achieving this goal
um and
a really good example of that is edcat
mall at Pixar because he talks about how
most
people are told when you have an idea
you need to like perfect your elevator
pitch when you're in the elevator with
someone higher up can you summarize your
idea in 30 seconds or less so they get
it but he's like anything that you can
summarize in 30 seconds or less is
actually not that original it's probably
derivative of something that's been done
before he's like if I was to explain
some of our top films to someone in 30
seconds it wouldn't make any sense Toy
Story that could end up like incredibly
commercial right like toys and and
whatever and America and capitalism like
it might not do well
um or Ratatouille a rat in a kitchen
that can cook like that's probably
disgusting and he's like it doesn't have
to make sense and I think that the thing
that he says that I love is like they go
through this iterative process to make
the film from really really bad just
less bad to less bad and then he's like
even when we put out the film we still
think it's [__] but like we just got to
the best possible version that we
thought we could get it to but it's not
the best you know so like sometimes you
have to let go and just put it out into
the world and see what happens
what do you think about somebody that
can release a
multi-award-winning series many
multi-award winning series on Pixar and
still not feel confident in the final
product
is just like creativity is just
a living animal I think I don't I don't
at least I don't know any creative
person who's ever like this is the
perfect final version of my creation and
and like I think I think even Da Vinci
was like you just some you just gotta
put it out there it's never Finn yeah I
actually think it was Da Vinci who said
uh like great art is never finished only
abandoned
so like it's it's really you you just uh
you get to the best possible version uh
that you can live with
that's interesting yeah I I'm trying to
be as positive as possible at the moment
just generally in everything to try and
counteract some cynicism that I'm seeing
a lot on the internet and uh
there is a bit of me that thinks
too much positivity not necessarily
positivity but too much satisfaction
kind of loses the edge that drove you
towards the maniacal obsessive Focus
that created the competitive advantage
in the first place
whether or not you can find a balance a
delicate balance between being driven by
the desire to do more whilst not fearing
the insufficiency of not being good
enough but if the head guy of Pixar says
that he's struggling as well then I
don't know maybe there's no hope for any
of us but when it comes when it comes to
inspiration
what have you learned about where that
comes from whether people should wait
for it to strike if if they need to
create an environment that engenders it
what about that
yeah I really do believe that activity
is a skill and it's not a muse or it's
not something external
um and I agree with your point that a
taste of success a taste of something
working or a creative act working can
bring about complacency and that's you
know every one hit wonder
and then they feel the pressure of the
second album or the second film or
whatever uh and or they became
complacent they just can't produce again
um the the thing about creativity that I
found is in in staying hungry is
constraint and like forcibly or forcing
yourself to start over in in various
ways so for example in the book I talk
about Grant Atkins who's like one of the
most Innovative chefs in the in the
country he's behind alinea um this
restaurant in Chicago and
he like for he makes his staff no matter
how popular the menu is he makes them
every six months just blow up the whole
menu and start over and it's just like
they hate it because they're like but
this works so well and he's like that
will make us uh complacent I want
originality I want creativity and I want
Innovation and the only way we can do
that is if we create these constraints
upon ourselves so we don't have to but
you're forcing yourself to reinvent
constantly there's a quote that says
unstructured freedom is the enemy of
true creative achievement find and learn
the rules you can break them afterwards
yeah there's a lot of um a direct like
film directors and like it creative
people in general who believe that rules
and structure can actually augment
creativity because if you know what the
rules are you can only then break the
rules if you don't know what the rules
are you're just like
you're finger painting you don't know
where the lines are and you don't know
where you can be Innovative so I think
like every great company like Spanx she
knew what the rules were but she was
like I want to play with within and
without like I want to break some rules
I want to create some rules so like you
can't break or invent rules if you don't
know what they are in the first place
yeah there's a difference between
disregarding convention
and believing that you can break the
physics of a system right like on
YouTube for instance
um something that we spend an awful lot
of time on thumbnail design and title
design and stuff like that we've been
able to get increasingly creative and
break conventions some conventions that
we've created but the only way that we
learned what those conventions were were
by following them for a while and this
is why the overnight success especially
in a creative Arena just I I don't it
doesn't happen it can take 10 years to
become an overnight success and the
latent leverage means that the
inflection curve is so vertical that it
feels like you're an overnight success
but you won't you had to learn all of
these different things the same goes
with music or guitar playing right my
housemate's a guitar player and it's his
skill developed he is now breaking rules
that he had to teach himself but if
you're just trying to disregard the
entire physics of the system you end up
with something that sounds like if I
tried to play it which is not good yeah
and just just one thing I I started
listening to your podcast really early
on like 2018.
2018. okay so so I was I was listening
really really early on and even though
the format the video like you added
video all this stuff Everything's
changed
you're the essence of it your creativity
and your questions have remained the
same and that's why like people like me
still listen because I I love the way
you think therefore like the the
fundamentals are there even if you've
broken the rules along the way
there's another one as well from Stephen
King which I really really love reminded
me a lot of um uh Stephen pressfield war
of art type scenario uh there is a muse
but he's not going to come fluttering
down into your writing room he lives in
the ground he's a basement guy you have
to descend to his level what's that mean
yeah okay so many people especially in
in Creative uh uh you know spheres they
talk about like oh I can't do this
because I don't feel inspired I I don't
I'm not in the right mood to create and
it's like I I guess because maybe
because I've been in journalism and
there's deadlines there's no like oh I
don't feel inspired to write it's like
you gotta write now uh because you have
to turn this in later so to me like it's
creativity has always been like yes you
can be creative but also you gotta sit
down like butt in chair and do the work
um and I think that for example when I
have complete unstructured freedom
without deadlines and without any sort
of structure I get lost and I never get
anything done and I think like he talks
about
um I think Stephen uh King has like I
write 1000 words a day like he he has
um fake deadlines that he's created for
himself but but uh he sticks to them
because it forces him to sit down and
work and I think like in today's society
like it people don't want to do the
freaking work
Jack butcher is a fantastic example of
this so he's a guy behind visualized
value and I remember I had a
conversation with him he is a graphic
designer by trade so he has played with
fonts and typography and colors and
shapes and Hues and all manner of
different ways to graphically represent
something in an interesting way when he
came to his magnum opus which is
visualize value anyone that's read the
almanac of Naval ravacan the
illustrations in that are from Jack he
constrained everything
white on black no color uh sort of uh
dot matrix geometric style illustrations
and the same font so all of the degrees
of freedom that a graphic designer
previously would have been playing with
have been removed and asked him why and
he said I've constrained that because
the highest point of contribution is
what is the concept that I'm explaining
and how well can I explain it I don't
want to get lost in should it be green
should it be red I changed this font and
do all the rest of it it's like no no
I've facilitated freedom in the most
important areas by constraining freedom
in the ones that don't matter it's also
constraint breeds creativity and also if
you look in the business World some of
the most iconic companies like uber
Airbnb
Etc started in times of constraint when
VCS weren't investing a ton of capital
when founders had to bootstrap when
there was a financial recession going on
2008-2009 that's when those companies
started but like you learn Financial
discipline and you learn how to uh you
learn that within constraint you can
figure out different ways to do things
instead of if you're like flush with
money and you're just like spending
everywhere you have no discipline
what did you learn about mental
toughness
so many things I know this is something
that you're very like an expert on and
you've actually interviewed David
Goggins who I talk about in the mental
resilience chapter but
I think the biggest thing that I learned
that I had never previously actually
thought about I I learned this while
writing the book and noticing these
patterns is that some of the most
mentally resilient people personify pain
and there's several examples I include
one is David Goggins who talks about how
he goes into this dark room to face
himself and he's super honest and he's
like you're fat you're lazy or a liar
like what are you gonna do about it
and then you know he exits that dark
room a different person then there's
um Courtney doll Walter who sees pain
she she talks about it as a place is
like again similarly to David Goggins
she sees it as a pain cave and she's
like I'm equally as in as control I'm in
control when I enter and I'm equally as
in control when I leave but it's like
this place of transformation and then
the third person that I talk about in
terms of this is um Anthony Ray Hinton
who uh he he was shoved into a a dark
place against his will because he was um
wrongfully in prison for 30 years on
death row and he was he often spent time
in a solitary confinement cell so
again a place of pain and suffering but
in that place he managed to keep his
mind sane by um visualizing like
different lives he could have had like
he talks about like having tea with the
queen or winning Wimbledon or marrying
Halle Berry and so
uh I I think that's so powerful because
if you personify pain and visualize it
as a place then you see that place as
something that can transform you so
David goggin says when you enter that
dark room and you face yourself
if if you don't break you'll transform
so it becomes like a place of like
Metamorphosis almost and and I love that
I I love that like visualizing it in
that way when talking about pain and
suffering one of the other things is
this sort of fine line I suppose between
self-criticism and self-accountability
and I think that people often get these
two confused you know there is a
subsection of the world that often talks
about you need to take more
responsibility for the things
um Joker willink extreme ownership and I
I don't disagree that maybe even on
average for most people lots of people
the majority of people uh this is a
strategy that's needed but I would guess
that for most of the people that are
listening to this podcast
they don't actually need that they
probably already over index for
accountability they believe that
something is their fault when they had
nothing to do with it a good example
let's say that I have a bad episode on
the podcast that the guest just doesn't
perform that day I blame me right it's
my fault I I should have guided them
better my question should have been
better I should have controlled the vibe
should have been a Vibe architect in a
more effective and sort of dexterous
manner but then if I guessed on a show
and that one goes bad that's still me
I'm like okay so I I do understand that
taking ownership for things is a smart
strategy but there is definitely a way
that you can overshoot that where you
just like
lambast yourself you're like whipping
yourself prostrated under the cat of
nine tails because
I don't know you're a [__] Puritan
I'm not really too sure but what about
this line between self-criticism and
self-accountability yeah I think um
actually Amelia Boone who she's a tough
moderate Champion
um I also talk about her in the book I
don't include this in the book but when
I talk to her she told me that she calls
this the Merry-Go-Round of
self-flagellation where like you think
you did something wrong but then you
focus on that thing but then you you
feel bad about it and then you feel bad
for feeling bad about it and you're just
like in a constant circle of this
um I think the way to get off is just
like yes like take responsibility but
then do what David Goggins does and he's
like what do you what am I gonna do
about it and I think if you've done all
the things that you think would
contribute to an episode going well then
you've done your job and then you're
just gonna have to let it go because I'm
sure you've noticed
some of your favorite conversations
maybe haven't performed as well as some
of the other ones where you're like that
was an okay conversation but like why is
this popping
um sometimes that you can make all the
right decisions but the outcome doesn't
match
yes victimhood mentality this sort of
pervasive victimhood mindset which is
the other side I guess of this a blade
that we're talking about what did you
learn about that
um yeah so uh Edith Eva eager she was a
holocaust Survivor and when she was on
the train to Auschwitz with her sister
and her mom her mom told her by the way
no matter what happens in the next few
weeks or months or years just remember
that everything can be taken away from
you except what you put into your own
mind and Edith as a teenager at the time
really took this to heart
um and it really carried her through
that horrific Journey
um but she talks about how every single
person will be on the receiving end of
some sort of victimization so she calls
it like the neighborhood bully the
spouse that cheats the you know the boss
who yells like those are all external
things that you're on the receiving end
of the victimization the victimhood
comes from the inside it's not external
it's only you can make yourself feel
like a victim and so I I think that like
this this is such a fine line and it's
exactly what you just said there's
extreme extreme ownership on one side
and then there's like internal
victimhood on the other and I think most
of society is kind of locked into one of
two extremes and we need to move towards
the middle somewhere where it's like I
take responsibility for my own thoughts
and my own actions but there's only up
to a point that I can control and and I
don't make myself feel like the victim
in every single situation even though I
will be victimized by life
um so I I keep that in mind it's almost
like a Continuum or like a spectrum
where you have to not over index on one
yeah this feels a lot like it's related
to the concept of talking to yourself
and listening to yourself and the
difference between those two yeah man
you really read my book Chris don't [__]
about Elena also your husband your
husband would have sent me a
actually I've got it here and everything
no it's proof I appreciate you I read it
I promise yeah
um no so the so yeah so listening to
yourself is basically when like you're
in pain let's say you're running a
marathon and like everything hurts and
you think you're dying and listening to
yourself would be oh my God my legs are
barely working how am I still running I
should stop whatever and then talking to
yourself is actively like taking control
over that internal narrator and not
letting it run on autopilot and instead
choosing what you tell yourself so
almost like a coach being like all right
you got this you only have like five
more miles to go your legs got you here
they'll get you there and you're just
like pumping like pumping yourself up to
not when you hit the wall to be able to
continue
uh I um I had a really bad in the
monologue and I still like it still
arises every so often probably more
frequently than I would like why
um
I can try and you know bro
psychoanalysis it but you know I was I
was
unsuccessful and largely a massive loser
until I pretty much got into University
and
um I think that the story I told myself
was that I'm not good enough that nobody
likes me why would anybody like me you
don't deserve love or acceptance or
praise or belonging
um I didn't really have a community of
friends to kind of uh ameliorate or
mediate any of that stuff so one of the
advantages which I know that you had
because you couldn't speak the language
when you first came to this country is
that you spend an awful lot of time
observing people which means that you're
very detail-oriented and you can detect
patterns which is why I became really
good at being a club promoter because I
could see what other people wanted and
then I'd reverse engineer that into a
nightclub but yeah I had this sort of
pretty pretty bad in a monologue I think
for a good chunk of time which again
still arises more than I want it to but
especially over the last two probably
the last six years since I was
meditating very consistently and
exposing myself more positive stuff and
then it's been really supercharged on
top of that strong Foundation within the
last 18 months since Living in America
because you guys are significantly more
extroverted and kind of positive about
everything and everything is going to be
fine people can take the piss as much as
they want but it's a really useful
strategy to have George Mack just
release an awesome Twitter Thread about
the rationalist's guide to like uh
positive affirmations or like
manifesting your dreams it's like
basically a rational optimism
justification and um
I know from first hand experience that I
can adjust I can nudge the inner voice
to now where it's pretty unrecognizable
it genuinely is I did a workout this
morning with Tim Kennedy and a bunch of
his psycho friends at Roca wow and this
workout was just awful like absolutely
45 minutes of hell and I remember
because I did CrossFit for a long time
about seven years ago
and I remember the texture of my mind
then and I know the texture of my mind
now and the difference is massive so you
know it's nice to think
that talking to yourself and nudging it
and assessing and listening back as well
to what's coming what's coming up is
something that can move you closer and
closer toward the world that you want
because we spend an awful lot of time
trying to change our external
environment but the texture of your own
mind is fundamentally the source code of
your existence and if you can nudge that
more
that's a huge uh increase in quality of
life
that's such a good way to put it and
also like the comparison you're able to
remember what you thought back then
versus now I think is huge because you
can see the you can see the difference
what about having healthy relationships
well
um so much
um so okay
so having health
y I was really interested in the
research of John gottman who with a
ridiculous amount of things like 94 97
really really high percentage of
certainty he can predict whether couples
will you know live happily ever after or
get divorced and he can do this just by
putting them in like an apartment like
lab setting in observing them and
um he found several things that can
predict marital stability that are so
counterintuitive and like kind of so
little that you're like really that's
that's it
um one of those things is when you ask a
couple like how they met
do they fondly remember the beginning
and kind of like joke about it and have
like a whatever or is it just a very
clinical and like cold like yeah we met
at this bar and that was it
um because I guess happier couples or
happier people tend to romanticize like
the past and the beginnings a little bit
more than uh more negative people the
other thing
um that he talks about is answering the
bid so throughout throughout the day
each one of us makes bids for attention
whether it's for a with a partner or a
friend or anybody else so when you make
a bid for attention you're like
hey look at this cool meme I just saw if
the person is like texting or not paying
attention to you and doesn't respond to
that bid you feel slighted but it's not
enough where you like get upset or mad
and he's like most relationships don't
fall apart because of one big blowout
fight they fall apart after years of
like chipping away at this um disrespect
in a way it's very small but it builds
up over time and then you resent each
other and you don't even know why and
it's because after years of like of this
not answering each other's bids even it
could be literally a head nod or or
whatever or a glance and the way he
measured this in the lab was he looked
at couples who answered each other's
bids like there was a couple who was
like oh you know look at this cool bird
pointed out the window and if the person
turned their head he was like they're
gonna last
so in that regard do you see love as a
skill that you develop yes I I do think
that like love is something
that can be learned like I will say like
I don't think I was a very good partner
early on because I always assumed and I
think like our society does this where
you always think that everything has to
be like magnificent and extraordinary
and life is about big moments when in
reality it's a lot more like I I can't
remember who said this but like I think
it was gottman
um Small Things occasionally Small
Things often is much more powerful than
big things occasionally and it's just
like we all think like what are you
doing for Valentine's Day what are you
gonna get me for my birthday but in
reality it's like the daily answering
the daily bid for attention is way more
important and significant than those big
moments so I think over time I learned
that it's like actually the small
ordinary moments that make a good life
than it is like the big grand gestures I
suppose even in a modern world that
applauds these big gestures and you can
upload them on Instagram everybody
expects it to be not totally [__] on
their birthday and October holy [__] on
Christmas and not totally [__] on New
Year's Eve so you go okay
the bar is set much higher for you to be
super impressive on somebody's birthday
because they were already expecting
something whereas the daily
um
how you permeate the physics of your
relationship like what
what is the foundation that all of this
is built on and then that stuff picks up
on top there's a quote that you had
trust compounds so does mistrust what's
that mean yeah well
um so it's like I talk about the
compound interest of trust and how like
all great returns whether Financial or
personal
um they pay interest and that interest
can be in the form of trust
um and like for example
Naval ravacant says that if you come
compound trust over a long period of
time uh then you can see all deals and
you can do a lot of really high impact
things with just the handshake because
you trust that person so much but the
only way you can build trust is to be
consistent over a long period of time
that's why I include the formula trust
equals consistency plus time because
it's like let's say you know you you
meet somebody for the first time and
you're about to go on a date and then
they cancel at the last minute that's
not detrimental to the relationship but
if they keep doing that over and over
like promising they're going to do
something and they keep breaking their
promise it's just it becomes really hard
to trust them
um so I think and I think um Shopify
founder Toby lutke I have to say his
name right
um he has this like idea that I love
where he's like when you first meet
someone
um you meet and you have each have a
trust battery and your trust battery
stays charged at 50 percent every single
interaction you have with that person
either discharges it or charges it a
little bit and he's like aimed to be a
person whose battery stays charged at
over 80 percent so basically most of the
things that you say you're gonna do you
end up doing uh so that it works in any
area of life in personal relationships
and business and with my newsletter
subscribers like it works with every
area
how should people tell better stories
um they should focus on conflict and
intent so
sorry
so uh basically when most people tell a
story there's some sort of intrigue
there's some sort of conflict but what
they forget is that it has to be laced
with intent in order for it to be
interesting one of the great
storytellers I talk about in the book is
Aaron Sorkin who's known for uh the film
he's known for many films but one film
is the social network which is the
Inception of Facebook and Mark
Zuckerberg and sorkin's like I'm not
interested in Tech I'm not interested in
startups I wasn't particularly
interested in Facebook the thing that
Drew me to this story is that there were
two different lawsuits against Mark and
he was defending himself so there was
Mark Zuckerberg a lawsuit from his buddy
Eduardo and also the Winklevoss twins
who claims he stole their idea and he's
like what I loved about this was that
there were three different versions of
the truth and there was no ultimate
truth and if you watch many of his films
many of his films play with perspective
and there's like not an ultimate source
of Truth
um so he talks about like
when you have a protagonist or a
character you need to show the conflict
they're mired in but also their intent
so he's like the intent maybe get to
Philadelphia get the girl get a sandwich
whatever it is it has to be compelling
enough that the character wants it and
he's like even better that he needs it
in Mark Zuckerberg's case he wasn't
chasing money he wasn't chasing anything
but Prestige and social status he had
been kind of like ignored by his peers
he wasn't invited to these like fancy
Club parties that they had at Harvard so
he wanted social status and Facebook was
his key to that even though he had all
this conflict he was determined to plow
through everything to get there so
anytime you're telling a story for
example if you're a Founder pitching a
company or you're someone you're trying
to date somebody or whatever present all
the challenges and the obstacles
standing in the way of what's going on
now maybe the company editors the market
landscape whatever and how you are going
to solve that problem because your
intent is why
there was some language tricks that my
housemate told me about I think from the
creators of South Park about using uh
but instead of and and I think that you
you found this as well yeah Aaron's
hurricane also says this he's like you
don't have a story unless you have the
words but a accept or and then so like
those words are what kind of make up a
story there's Intrigue there's suspense
there's mystery
yes I remember so when I first started
the show which you'll remember because
you've been listening since I thought um
I was like kind of obsessed with uh
productivity that was my thing it was
like a productivity bro for a good while
and adamant if I just refined my getting
things done to-do list task manager and
I did enough pomodoros that all of my
problems would fade away and like
spoiler alert they didn't but
I also took that across I think into the
philosophy of the show or at least my
like how I showed up in the beginning by
thinking right my job as a podcaster is
to ruthlessly index all of the key
points that this guest has and then
distill them down like uh blinkist or
short form for whichever person I was
speaking to and over time and again this
is learning the rules before you can
break the rules I've realized that just
being a Vibe architect is much more
important and getting stories out Vibe
architect yeah I know I I should
trademark it
um like trying to elicit and not not
unnecessary Superfluous stories but you
know David goggin's book uh his first
one can't hurt me is a good example the
best selling self-published book in
history
there's things that you can take from it
but there's nothing that isn't couched
in a story like don't make a point
without the story and don't tell a a
story without a point and yeah just over
time that's that's really sort of been
reinforced to me like try and
almost be overly Whimsical with it you
know you can lean into a little bit of
drama and Intrigue and add unnecessary
uh detail into stuff because that's what
fleshes this thing out and and
fundamentally we're a storytelling
species which I think actually drives
the point home better than if you've
just given the Tweet length summary of
what the person believed it's in it it's
largely that we we tell stories to make
points because stories trigger emotion
and empathy and
emotion triggers memory so I'm more
likely to remember a point that is
captured in the story because I can
empathize with whoever's going through
whatever they're going through and I
actually I like overdosed on you and
George Max content in 2018 because of
exactly this like
many of the podcasts I would listen to
were kind of like surface level or they
let the the guests
just say facts like which is fine but
what I really appreciated about you that
you always did is you took out the
Practical takeaways that I could apply
to my own life because that's why I was
listening I wanted like every single
time somebody's listening to a speech or
listening to a podcast or watching a
video
selfishly you know without knowing it
they want to take something away
personally they're not just like
listening because you're a really good
speaker they're like how can I apply
this to my own life and that's why I
wrote the book this way I'm like yes
these are human stories but each one of
them contains a little nugget that you
can like take away and Implement in your
own life today yeah one of my friends
uses the term does it grow corn
it's like this is it's lovely I like the
idea it's fantastic compelling
motivating whatever but like
show me show me does this thing grow
[__] corn like can it turn this
tilled ground into something useful that
I can eat and I think that
um again you know it's the following the
rules before you can break them thing
you can totally go down the emotion Pawn
story Whimsy roots for forever and then
you look back on a conversation or or a
a book or a you know a movie and realize
I didn't actually take anything away
from that it was you know a remotely
enjoyable Journey but the uh outcome
that I got at the end of it was no con
yeah
no corn oh I love that it's cool all
right what about becoming a more
effective leader
yeah so I think that the best leaders
approach it from a Bottoms Up
perspective rather than a top-down
approach one good example is
um Spotify founder and CEO Daniel Eck he
is very much he wanted to create a
culture of like Bottoms Up leadership
he's like the employees are the
lifeblood of this company I want to as
the CEO be there so I can guide them and
give them resources and kind of fuel
their ideas but their ideas Drive the
company so this really came to a head
when there was this team that was
working on a new feature and they're
really excited about it about it they
were like what if we created a
personalized play playlist for every
single like listener of spotify and
Daniel I heard this idea and he was like
honestly like I wasn't really excited
about it I thought this is kind of
stupid why are you spending all this
time and energy on this
um would it be just like a tiny feature
and then they were like eh but they kept
working on it given even though he was
like not enthusiastic about it and then
they ended up like launching it to the
public without telling him and he read
about it in the Press just like
everybody else and he was like I
remember reading about this and I was
like oh my God this is going to be a
total disaster I can't believe they did
this but then that turned into discover
weekly which is like one of spotify's
most loved features and he's like that
would have never been possible if they
didn't feel the freedom and like have
the agency to do that because like if
you're terrified of your boss you're
never gonna do that you're never gonna
ship something without telling the CEO
but the fact it speaks to the culture of
that company they were able to do that
uh and and that it was successful what's
the difference between that and servant
leadership
it's it's similar uh servant leadership
was something popularized by Robert
Greenleaf uh which is basically the CEO
is there to serve
um uh the employees of the company and
Mark bertolini who is now co-ceo of
Bridgewater but he used to be the CEO of
Aetna the large insurance company
um he he has something he calls like the
four levels of Taoist leadership and
he's like the first level is that your
employees hate you the second is that
they fear you the third is that they
praise you and the fourth is that the
company runs itself because you're
invisible so if you think about it most
leaders they don't want to become
invisible they want to be needed they
want people to say like this company
can't operate without this person but
actually the highest level of like
leadership is that you've run this
organization so well and you've trained
everybody so well that the company can
go into the future without you and he in
his final chapter at Aetna ended really
successfully because he was able to kind
of Shepherd it the sale to CVS uh health
and then the company went on without him
and it's just like I think it speaks to
the priorities of certain leaders and
why some of them do much better than
others Ben Francis CEO of gymshark on
the podcast that I did with him said
when your Ambitions for the business are
bigger than your Ambitions for yourself
that's when you'll truly be a leader
basically that he founded the company
then became CEO then step down as CEO
and then got re-instated as CEO all
because those were the best decisions
for the business and he didn't have the
ego to hold on this is my company and
it's my position and I want to be at the
head so I just want to do whatever's
best for gymshark I want to grow this
company though because you have to put
your ego aside which is like the hardest
thing yeah you mentioned there about
um making yourself redundant as the
ultimate goal that all owners or
Founders I think should aspire to and
everybody is addicted to systems and and
trying to automate what do you think
gets overlooked when it comes to
designing systems and automations for
our lives
for our lives yeah and for business as
well like the way that we interact with
our professional in our personal world
yeah I think so I think most of us get
too focused on the outcome
um versus creating the right system
um and chess players talk about this a
lot like when they evaluate a game they
look at the systems not necessarily like
that one mistake that they make because
they're like okay if I just focus on the
mistake I can focus on not making that
one exact same mistake again but if you
think in terms of systems you're like
where where did the the fundamentals
Break
um and then you can focus on not making
that mistake and like future of hundreds
of similar mistakes like that one if you
get the fundamentals right can you think
of a less Chessy analogy that might be
uh more like obvious for people to
follow yeah yeah okay so for example
like let's say you want to run a
marathon and the outcome is
I want to run a marathon I want to keep
running marathons whatever but like you
can train for that one marathon and you
can do it and then that's it you're
never going to run again or you I I ran
a marathon then didn't run it all for a
year but I think like the point is if
you get the systems right you can I
think James Clear says you don't win
once you win every single day you become
a runner if you have like it becomes a
way of life instead of just focused on
this one outcome
um so you have like a training plan but
also like you find a way to build it
into your life and that's what for
example James Clear talks about with
identity based habits is you become the
person and you don't just focus on the
one outcome yeah there's a I remember
from his book he says if you uh do a key
ppap with the football does that make
you a footballer no if you go and play
one game in the park does that make you
a footballer no well what about if if
you play every weekend for two years
yeah well most people would probably say
yeah you're a footballer now you play
football and so there is a line at some
point that is based off the back of
repetition routine consistency
commitment uh well it's indicative of
commitment right that's what the the
consistency is like
the uh the projection of the internal
commitment you can be as internally
committed to being a footballer as you
want but if you never kick a football
then you're not uh there's a cool quote
as well don't look at the scoreboard
play the next play I love that yeah Nick
Saban from his uh college football coach
of Alabama he's he's often reminding
players not to look at the scoreboard
but just to focus on doing their One
Singular job because they're all part of
a larger system because if I do my job
and you do your job and the third person
does their job then the outcome will
take care of itself it's like stop
looking at the scoreboard just like play
the next play correctly and execute it
right
what about taking risks how can people
become better at taking risks
oh man
um so so risk taking there there's so
much
um I think we live in a very uncertain
world at the moment uh and there's
there's a lot to it's like it almost
feels like there's a lot of like
information coming in uh and we don't
have enough answers but what I found is
that a lot of times you have to evaluate
and calculate risk properly in order to
make the best decision in the book I
talk about several stories but one of
them is
um Jim Cook who's the founder of Samuel
Adams beer he worked at Boston
Consulting Group as a consultant and he
was making 250 000 a year which in
today's dollars is like a million
dollars a year and he was like oh I
really want to quit my job and leave
this amazing salary and start a brewery
to make American Beer you not being from
the US you know how the jokes especially
in the 90s and early 2000s was that
United Americans can't make beer
American beer tastes like water and
water can be arguably stronger than
American Beer
um German beer is normally yeah so so he
um his great great grandfather had
immigrated from Germany to the U.S and
when Jim was like looking in the family
attic for something he came across an
old beer recipe from his great great
grandfather and he was like What if I
take this recipe and make an American
Beer that actually has flavor
um and uh and so he he kept like toying
with this idea but it was a really big
risk for him to leave his cushy job to
do this and so he started thinking about
two words which are
um
scary and dangerous and he was like the
scary decision is telling my boss
telling my wife giving up the salary
like whatever but scary only lasts like
a few days like you'll get over telling
your boss or disappointing your college
professor whatever it may be that you're
scared of but dangerous is staying in
this job and then when I'm 80 years old
looking back and be like damn I wish I
started that Brewery so it's like you
want to make the scary decision and then
in terms of like you don't want to stay
in the dangerous one because that could
be forever and so if you were like
making a decision right now and you
think is it risky is it not a good
framework is is this decision scary or
is it dangerous in which path am I on
right now
before I made the move to America I rang
George and George had already pulled the
PIN to go out to Dubai because we'd
spent a month in Dubai to flee British
lockdowns in 2020 and he loved it and he
was having a great time out there and I
was like dude you know I'm gonna have to
let go of this
previous version of me that I thought I
was this club promoter and this success
and and Accolade and notoriety and I'm
thinking about going and doing this
thing in America but you know I
started talking to people on the
internet and accidentally made it a job
isn't it doesn't exactly fill me with
tons and tons of like this is definitely
going to work and I'm so naturally
risk-averse like unbelievably prudent as
a decision maker and he introduced me to
reversible and irreversible decisions
yeah
yeah he was like look what's the worst
that happens you go out there it doesn't
work out you come back with your tail
between your legs and in a couple of
weeks time everybody's forgotten but the
alternative is so I think that the
um whatever scary and dangerous risky
and dangerous
yeah scary scary and scary and dangerous
and reversible and irreversible sort of
map over the top of each other quite a
lot too I also include that question and
there too the basically you want to make
reversible decisions quickly uh that you
can learn a lot from but make
irreversible decisions deliberately and
slowly because some of those you know
may not they're irreversible you can't
go back if you have a child you're going
to be a parent for the rest of your life
but if you move or like if you quit your
job you can always go get another job
that's reversible so it's like if you
don't have a ton of Prior information
just make the reversible decision
quickly what about that story from Chris
Hadfield
yeah
um so he Chris hadfield's crazy
incredible and interesting but he's an
astronaut at one point he was on a
spacewalk outside of the International
Space Station holding on with one arm
doing work on it when his like left eye
slammed shut he was like what the hell
just happened he went temporarily blind
on a spacewalk outside of the ISS and
the reason that happened is um some like
small there was like a mixture of soap
and oil that they used to clean their
advisors it got caught inside of his
helmet and into his eye but because
there's no gravity that thing just like
became a blob and then it went over into
his other eye so he's like now totally
blind outside of the ISS and
most people would panic in a situation
like that but the way he saw it was like
I know that my first reaction is panic
but I can give myself optionality and I
think that's what people forget a lot
when they're in like uncertain or risky
situations it's like what can I do right
now what action can I take to give my
future self optionality and he he was
like okay right now I have three options
I can call Houston I can get my fellow
astronaut like Scott persinski to rescue
me or I can cry a little bit and let it
dilute out of my eye he ended up doing a
fourth thing which is opening a vent on
the side of his helmet to let some
oxygen out help it evaporate and then he
continued working and
um Chris has been in kind of like
impossible situations to most of us he
one time fixed an ammonia leak on the
ISS another time he broke in to a space
station I think yeah another one not
that it's a a space station with a Swiss
army knife and a third time he does
disposed of a live snake while piloting
a plane so like all these things
obviously you can't plan for but when
they happen you've you have the skills
because he's an astronaut or a pilot or
whatever and he's had training
um you're competent enough to figure it
out and give yourself options and he
always says competence breeds confidence
so even when you're in like seemingly
impossible situations it's important to
remember like by the way this is not the
first risky thing I've done or uncertain
situation I've been in and all those
other times I figured it out and I'm
here today so like it wasn't a life or
death situation so he talks about
um how when you're literal and you're
learning to ride a bike the bike is
really dangerous and you see it as this
like death trap you're like I could get
on I could fall I could break a leg
break my head but then as you get more
competent and better the bike gets
becomes silly to be afraid of so he says
people
um no things aren't scary people get
scared so another another way in other
terms the bike itself never changed it's
just as dangerous as it always was but
you are the one who changed and I think
like that's how it is in life as you get
more and more competent it's silly to
become to to still be fearful of
uncertainty because you know you have
the skills to figure it out well that's
the problem right the
um asking for confidence without
competence is Wishful fantasy yes and
you know having no confidence whilst
having competence is self-delusion you
know you can have I call it imposter
adaptation which is the Imposter
syndrome continues to persist even as
you disprove it every single day and
after a while after you've disproven it
enough times you end up realizing that
it's got nothing to do with your ability
to do a thing and everything to do with
your ability to feeling like an imposter
like you're addicted to feeling like an
imposter
absolutely
um
Lewis Hamilton as well another person
who performs high speed very risky
maneuvers you had to look at him right
yeah yeah yeah he um he's fascinating
because he sees himself as like a master
of his craft so he you know he's a race
car driver but he's like I'm never done
learning and improving and you'll find
that the most successful people like
just really enjoy tinkering with their
craft until they feel like they're
masters of it
um but but I think the point with Lewis
is like you're never done learning and
you're constantly getting better and
better and more competent uh and like
you said like confidence is hollow
without having the things to back it up
and I think you see it often like with
with podcast hosts who are just starting
they want to like they want people to
perceive them as confident and to
respect them immediately but it's like
you have to earn that respect and
through reps and like many many
conversations so um so I think like I I
love the idea of Lewis of just
constantly what does he calling he calls
it like painting a masterpiece or
something but you're are constantly
putting little splashes of paint on that
masterpiece
yeah I wrote something down for a
potential newsletter
um it sat in my notes at the moment and
it says uh you're not ready for the
audience you want to have which is a lot
of people and me too right for to so
long was adamant the show's under
subscribed the show's under subscribed I
would listen to this why why people more
people not listening to it and I still
think that that's the case but
I wasn't ready to have the level of
scrutiny that I do now because when that
thing kicks in and when 25 million
people a month are watching you you'd
better have some skills because the
level of scrutiny is going to be so high
that if you don't you're going to get
eaten alive you're not ready for the
size of platform that you want to have
that is so true and you don't you
haven't had the time to develop like the
thick skin necessary to emotionally deal
with that correct so clarifying your
thinking one of the reasons that I love
this chapter apart from the fact that
I'm big into Clarity of thought is that
will store and Rob Henderson two of my
boys were in it
yeah
I love this chapter I feel like this
chapter doesn't get enough enough like I
I've done a few podcasts and nobody ever
asked me about this
um so I love that so the reason in 2018
I think I was drawn to your podcast is
because I was trying to like force
myself into becoming a more rational
thinker I was like very much driven by
emotion and
um I think you and I have like some
similarities in terms of like feeling
like Outsiders or bullying or things
like that like I I get it
um so when I was trying to like become
like a more rational logical thinker
um I came across several things uh but
one of them was I was always obsessed
with the idea of like why people join
Cults I'm like what kind of person does
it take to join a call and it's very
much like built on a belief system in
like a black and white tribal like we
believe this you will become this type
of person and um and James Clear talks
about how like the reason it's so hard
to get people to change their belief
even though they are absurd is because
you're not asking them to change their
beliefs you're asking them to change
their tribe so the people that they've
surrounded themselves with whether it's
politically or however you attach your
identity to whatever
you are asking people to like leave
those people find a new friend group
find a new support system and like
that's really hard to do so this whole
chapter just breaks down like how can
you become more of a scout instead of a
soldier when talking about uh beliefs
and information how can you
um better gather the facts and then
analyze them and and create a more
accurate picture of reality versus being
a soldier which Julia gailiff talks
about how you protect you defend you
want your piece of information your
belief to win and approaching life more
as a scout is much more powerful
how do you go about separating what are
our beliefs compared with what have been
absorbed just from others or societal
Norms or passive lease resistance or
trauma responses or whatever how do we
actually know
how do we get clear enough in our
thinking that we know what we think yeah
I uh so okay
um
I think Elon Musk tweeted this once and
it stuck with me and it was just
basically like you need to build a
really really powerful mental firewall
because whether you like it or not
people's beliefs are going to seep into
your mind and then you're going to
confuse them for your own and that's why
I earlier I asked you the negative inner
monologue like where you think that
comes from because for a lot of people
it's actually not them it's actually
their abusive parent or the bully at
school or like whatever it's something
you heard that you ended up
internalizing without questioning and um
I also when I read Tara westover's
Memoir educated she talks about like how
the first time she set foot in college
she was like I had sexist homophobic
racist beliefs that I said out loud and
that people were able to challenge and
only then did I realize that I myself
don't know why I believe this but those
weren't my words those are my father's
words because as a kid you don't
question it you just like you download
Somebody else's software into your own
hardware and then it's very hard to
separate like what's yours and what
somebody else's yeah I think especially
for people that like to consume a lot of
content that you know consider
themselves curious introspective
reflective ruminative types of people
you can quite easily
cage yourself in a way that a less
introspective person couldn't like
there's there's a double-edged sword to
being smart right that yeah you you're
able to guard yourself against uh other
sources of counterfactual information
more aggressively you know the the
um
fortification that you've managed to
place yourself in ideologically
intellectually in terms of world view is
so strong that you can become a slave to
your beliefs very easily because the
beliefs are so in your view well
grounded yes precisely absolutely and
and I think like for example I I've
never held
a belief so strongly that I was willing
to like fight people on the internet
over it or anything like that maybe
that's that's a fault of mine but
actually I think that this the like my
biggest strength is that I can empathize
with most people because I see different
perspectives because I always feel like
an outsider and yeah like I moved from
Bulgaria to Georgia and then to New York
as an adult but as a child
um coming to this country and then like
seeing the cultural norms and how people
think and the way they whatever I notice
every single thing and when you don't
speak English you're forced to observe
people and you're like why do they
always sit there in the cafeteria you
become really really good at social
skills
um without knowing it
um and then and then you move to New
York and people in New York are like I
can't believe people in Georgia believe
this one thing and I'm like I really I
can tell you exactly why they think that
and it's like I I'm constantly like
switching roles even if I go back to
Bulgaria people would be like oh that's
where you feel at home like that's where
you're an Insider but actually I feel
much more like an outsider there because
now I'm too American and now I have like
thinking you know I can see why these
people think this way whatever but um
but I really do believe that the people
who get sucked into these like
ideological culture wars are people who
have not had many experiences or people
who haven't been around a diverse enough
uh group of people I'm pretty sure that
60 of Americans don't have passports
exactly
so you know you're very well traveled
world view going from New York to
Upstate New York to New Jersey doesn't
exactly give you the world's perspective
that you think you might and this is how
you end up being myopic because you
don't actually ever
get outside of your own bubble and then
you know this isn't the echo chamber
that is facilitated by online media this
is the like geographically you don't
move that far you haven't seen many
other things or eaten other Foods or
been to different places or spoken to
Alternative people but in
traveled look at the people that you
surround yourself with are they really
people with like a diverse set of
experiences in life uh you know
obstacles that they've had to overcome
where you can see a different
perspective and just because somebody
looks a certain way doesn't mean that
they've haven't undergone whatever kind
of trauma in their past
what would you say talking about
Community Building what would you say
are the biggest pitfalls that people
encounter when it comes to building a
community what are the ways that you
could ensure that a community would fail
um if you want to grow really fast
really big really fast without taking
the time to do the work person by person
by person
um Troy Carter who used to be Lady
Gaga's manager said with Lady Gaga they
implemented this approach called it was
the slow bake versus the microwave in
terms of audience retention and audience
growth Lady Gaga would play you know
little clubs every single night meet the
people interact with them on social
media like it was super individualized
and then those people became her
spokespeople and it snowballed into a
massive mass of following uh but you
know that they're so loyal because of
the early days of Lady Gaga
um Taylor Swift another thing that I
think people try to do that is like
um they they uh they do the thing that
scales because they think that'll bring
them more people instead of the
non-scalable thing and I think it's the
non-scalable thing that actually builds
more loyalty Taylor Swift you'll notice
she I mean she has a global phone she
doesn't need to do this stuff but she
knows if she does this these people are
Taylor Swift fans for life which is she
randomly shows up shows up at people's
weddings which is incredibly cumbersome
like time consuming thing she um
surprises fans by going through her
social media finding random people and
like sending them gifts and they're just
like what on Earth or she invited
again people she found on her Instagram
to her house she bake them cookies and
she let them listen to like uh the
newest album before it was released so
these are all like super non-scalable
things but why is Taylor Swift doing
them she already has a massive following
it's because she doesn't want to just
have an audience she wants to build
miniature communities right and like
really really tight-knit communities
um and I think the final thing the thing
that I think most creators who have big
followings should do is try to create
moments of serendipity that your
followers may not get in any other way
so at one point um I got inspired by Tim
Urban's he has he has weight but why
which is the blog but he created an
event called wait but high and on the
same day all over the world his readers
got together London everywhere so I was
like I want to do the same thing at the
time the profile only had 10 000 people
so I was a little bit over ambitious but
still
um we did one weekend in December and
there were people in like New York
Atlanta London Nairobi Kenya even if
there were only two people the thing
that brought them together was reading
the profile and um and I remember the
guys from Nairobi wrote to me and they
said we came together as strangers and
we we left as friends and the point of
that is like that was a moment of
serendipity there's still groups that
still meet up like I think the one in La
so it's just like there there's there's
you can create these moments of
serendipity but that's a true community
and I think
author Chris Brogan says the difference
between audience and Community is which
way the chairs are facing so if you're
only one channel communication meet a
mini that's an audience but if you if
the chairs are in a circle and if
there's constant interaction between you
and your listeners and your readers and
whatever that's community
so much good stuff there I love the uh
non-scalable things being the high
impact things because they're a costly
signal right you know anybody can send
out an email newsletter with a video
that's been taken for everybody but only
one person can receive a personalized
video that's been sent in their
Instagram DMS from Lady Gaga yeah we've
been um you might have seen I'm doing
live shows at the end of the year uh
Island and the UK and at that there's a
there is an incentive to sell VIP
tickets right and as with a you know a
Peterson uh type show or a Sam Harris or
a heberman that's you know maybe 1500 to
3 000 bodies uh they can't do uh meet
and greet for everybody so they need to
Arbitrage it and then you just take that
same model and do it yourself that's
typically how stuff's supposed to be
done and that was the advice that we
were given look if you want to maximize
Revenue
um you should have scales of ticket vvip
they get to go backstage beforehand and
you look at the difference in terms of
the bottom line because live shows don't
make that much money and you're like wow
that would be nice like that would be
that would be lovely that's just free
free bottom line I don't have to do
anything different it's just free bottom
line but I spoke to my tour manager and
both of us said look
if if this ends up being something
that's cool and that we start doing
consistently we can do that in future
but given that these are the first ever
shows that we're doing how much cooler
would it be if everybody just got to do
a meet and greet so all it's going to be
like two and a half thousand people over
the space of four days but you
yes fights a lot
um but like I don't know that just seems
cool and there's also something as well
when it comes to building a community
and getting buy-in
you have the opportunity to and this
goes back to you are not ready for the
size of the audience that you want
you have the opportunity to track the
journey step by step over time and you
know let's say that you do get to the
top of the mountain whatever industry or
world or Pursuit it is that you're
trying to get to looking back and having
a cool origin story is really really
good like and
honestly the [__] the better like the
[__] the first few iterations of
whatever you do I genuinely think the
better it is when you look back because
it creates a lower bar for the current
High bar to now be compared to and uh
yeah I think first set of live shows
everybody gets to do meet and greet
that's going to be cool it's going to
feel really personal and intimate and
then if we sell out Sydney Opera House
in three years time you look back and go
[__] dude you remember when we did 500
people on a reigning Friday in the
middle of Manchester and we went and met
everybody in that Pub afterward but
those like 500 or 2 000 people are never
going to forget that
um who was it I think it's like is it
Will Smith I forget who said it but it
was like some celebrity it was like I
always stop and take a photo with the
fan because to me it's just another
photo but to them they're gonna remember
this for the rest of their lives and
like how do you want that experience to
go so I think like that's the
non-scalable thing like these people
this will be Monumental to them when you
are uh you know
um selling out stadiums and whatever
they're gonna be like I was there one of
those 2 000 people and I had this
experience like I think that's awesome
one of Jordan Peterson's hacks and this
is for anybody that's getting more
attention than they used to and getting
stopped on the street and I've I've
taken this as well so this is like when
people see me that the source code's
going to be revealed and ruined but
um Peterson Peterson taught me
um that whenever he meets somebody
because he's met you know like [__]
hundreds of thousands of people the
first thing if it's if it's in the
middle of the street the first thing he
always asks is what's your name because
you know someone's meeting Jordan
Peterson and maybe they've consumed a
lot of his content and they're feeling
all emotional and they're really really
excited but everybody can remember their
name everyone knows their name so you
say hi what's your name hi John really
nice to meet you and then the
conversation begins flowing and then
this was something that I added on which
hopefully is is Meaningful I'm really
bad at remembering names like [__]
terrible remembering names but I work
super super hard if I do do that as I
say goodbye it's Tom it was really nice
to meet you hope you have a good day man
and I know I hope that that it's it is
effort like it's [__] hard to
remember someone's name it's really
embarrassingly difficult
um but yeah I hope that that's something
that's cool so I've taken Peterson's
strategy and added a a parentheses at
the start and the end of the same thing
I'm the same way even when I'm
responding to emails when readers write
in I always end with like I always
mention their name uh one time I think I
read this somewhere somebody said like
the best compliment somebody can receive
is like the sound of their own name or
something like that you you love hearing
that especially from people that you
admire
talk to me about why it's important to
optimize your content diet this is
something that I've been very very big
on for probably the last 18 18 months to
two years so why is it important to you
so okay so a few years ago uh let's say
2017 I was like binge watching The
Bachelor The Bachelorette every dating
show you watch Love Island UK I hope
that you did but I still need to watch
it I know we're not going to be you're
not going to be friends with me anymore
no I love that it's a different lifetime
I get like really absorbed into people's
stories so
um so I was like watching all this stuff
and I started realizing that I started
seeing the world through this like prism
of relationships but in a really bad way
like in a way that was like oh I wonder
if he's mad at me or I wonder what she
thinks of me or I wonder if like you
know like that kind of like insecure
thing that you hear on these shows
constant questioning myself and like
hyper self-awareness instead of like
using my mind to think about other
things so then I started thinking about
this idea of like how we're so cognizant
of what we eat in the portions and what
type of diet and and what percentage of
meat what percentage of whatever so I
was like what if we did that with
content and it's like a Content diet
which doesn't mean you can't still watch
your dating shows it just it's not the
bulk of your diet it's maybe a sliver
um so I think like what I I conducted I
called it a Content audit so I I
genuinely like was very realistic of
like what do I listen to what do I watch
what do I read and who do I hang out
with on a daily basis
um once you are able to see what you're
putting into your brain then you realize
like am I filling it with like
interesting ideas or am I just kind of
like mindlessly going about my day
um and once you do that you have to make
it practical if you want to read more
high quality content stop like reading
headlines and click bait for me it was
like starting the profile I was forced
every week to read these long-form
profiles and like kind of synthesize it
it was a forcing function like create
something in your life that you can't
get out of that forces you to do that
um and then and then I found like I
became a more interesting person
ironically because I started reading
more interesting things and talking to
more interesting people
um so that's that's kind of the idea and
like since then I I'm always very
mindful that
the people you can really tell what
people what their content diet is based
on how they view the world
I have a friend who said if you want to
know who somebody truly is you don't
need to give them a personality test or
take them in for psychometric evaluation
just look at their YouTube suggested
feed between the hours of 10 pm and 11
pm at night
oh my God that's hilarious so good
um so something that I was playing with
for a while and I use as a life hack a
few months ago on the the newsletter was
um how do you feel after you consume a
piece of content so you know there are a
variety of different shows that you can
watch on YouTube or on TV at the like
limbically hijack you right you know
it's people shouting at each other it's
it's adversarial antagonistic it's
backbiting it's snarky it's sarcastic
and it it gets you compelled but it gets
you compelled in the same way as being
shocked with an electrode gets you
compelled and if you feel the way that
your body feels after you consume this
stuff you're uptight and and your
shoulders are high and you've almost got
tinnitus in your ears because
everything's just activated you're just
super super like sympathetically
switched on and it's not it's not good I
don't want to go outside and call my
friends and tell them that I miss them I
don't want to go and play sports I don't
have a positive some mindset I don't
believe that the world is fundamentally
a good place and then I watch other
things and I'm like oh [__] yeah like I
should ring my mum I should ring my mum
and I should tell that I'm thinking
about her that I miss her and that for
me is you know if somebody's listening
and they say oh this content diet thing
sounds great and I wonder how to do it
but your felt sense and your remembered
sense of what's going on are always
going to be different right because your
felt sense whenever you're watching
anything by virtue of you watching it
means that you're not bored by it so the
felt sense is is kind of you kind of
need to disregard how you feel as you
watch it
and then very quickly afterward I think
yeah you've got the perspective to be
able to see it okay so I have a very
similar thing but I do it with I've
always said this like whenever I meet
somebody even if in the moment I'm
absolutely like captivated by them and
they're so Charming how do I feel once
they've left like for some reason my
brain can't decide how I feel about
someone until after like I'm by myself
I'm like whoa was that was that just
like a snake oil salesman you know what
I mean like you you're able to
um evaluate it better after you've had
some separation from it so I like this
idea of like how do you feel after
you've watched it because while you're
watching it it might be amazing and like
stimulating but like afterwards like how
do you really feel like a piece of [__]
sometimes yeah George is in town I don't
know whether you knew but George is in
Austin at the moment oh nice so you guys
he's going to come on yeah which would
be the first one
two three years I think and we've got so
much [__] to go through
um but
he is one of those guys when I leave
having spent time with him we were at
Soho house on Sunday in Austin Sat by
the pool and ordering food and just
chilling out and um I leave and I feel
rejuvenated and I've got loads of new
ideas and I've been hearing stories
about Winston Churchill and NASA and you
know God knows what like the Persian
Empire and I I just leave and I'm like
yeah this is nice the Sun's shining a
bit brighter you know the colors look a
bit more vibrant and there's other times
when you consume things or do even like
doing particular tasks you know like how
do you spend your time like I love I
really love being on Tick Tock overall
or being on my phone overall or or
playing video games or whatever and
that's fine if you feel great afterward
but the period of life after you do a
thing lasts way longer than the period
of time of you doing the thing and
largely what you're looking for are just
little pokes of
uh uh who do you say
yeah yeah just little little nudges each
day when you do a thing and it just
keeps on pushing you in one direction or
another and you need to make sure that
you're being pushed in the right
direction so the Final Chapter which is
title of the book what does it mean like
what what is a hidden genius you've got
this like sort of silhouette thing on
the front here
um I don't know if you're are you one of
these is that are you any of these
little Silhouettes you should have been
more weight way more egotistical and
narcissistic and put yourself high
profile yeah um no uh so hidden genius
it's just really that differentiator
that makes you exceptional and I am
optimistic enough to believe that each
of us has hidden genius but many of us
just have not taken the time or been
aware enough to discover it and
it could be like a piece of wisdom it
could be an experience it could be a
skill set something that you've acquired
that you uniquely know or a point of
view of the world that you can share
with others and you can teach others if
you think about like David Goggins maybe
he's not classically intelligent on like
an IQ test maybe he is but I don't know
but but but his hidden genius is his
mental resilience and the fact that he's
sharpened his mind so well that it's
like a weapon
um so so it's just like it can be found
in anybody the the packaging is not this
like classical actually I remember I
think when I was talking to the
publisher about titles they were like I
don't know like genius kind of has that
connotation that people think of like
Einstein and whatever and that's not at
all what I what I think Geniuses
um so in this chapter I talk about
the ingredients that you've been reading
up to now and I think hidden genius
starts with identity and like
if you've noticed throughout the book
there's been themes and layers of
playing with perspectives and also like
playing with identity who you are if I
ask you like who's the real Chris is it
Chris 10 years ago is it Chris yesterday
is it Chris today or is it Chris in 10
years
there is that like it's so you but like
who is the real you and um and I think
like figuring out that tying your
identity to one single thing isn't what
makes you you helps you discover your
hidden genius and then in the conclusion
I have
10 questions that will hopefully get you
closer to that answer
does this stand Gilbert quotes which you
use which is so good human beings are
Works in progress that mistakenly think
that they're finished yeah
yeah because if you think about it
biologically speaking you are not the
same person you were 10 years ago I
think your stomach lining uh is every
few years your like livers ever like
everything regenerates so it's like are
you you're biologically different but
like are you spiritually the same like
how do you define that yeah it's um
I can't remember who who's quoted as
that says the funny thing about life is
that it has to be lived forward but only
makes sense in reverse and understanding
where you're at at the moment believing
that you're the finished article and yet
also knowing that you're a work in
progress is is an odd Duality to try and
hold you got this I was surprised to see
Francis and ganu in here
I know that if I fail I can start over
and over and over and over I have that
skill and you can take everything from
me but you cannot take that I thought
that was so powerful yeah he yeah I just
I took a lot from him even though I know
nothing about MMA I think that his brain
and the way it works is fascinating and
uh when I interviewed him um basically I
he's had this crazy journey to get to
the states
um including like going from Cameroon to
Niger Niger to Nigeria Nigeria to
Algeria Algeria to Morocco in Morocco to
Spain and from Spain eventually he she
was homeless in Paris ultimately he made
it to America through MMA and I told him
that my family won the Green Card
Lottery and he was like oh well I used
to play that too but like I would never
leave my destiny in somebody else's
hands I was like ah right but um way to
make me feel like a piece of [__]
exactly no but his point was that like
he was like maybe if I had won the Green
Card lottery I would have made it to the
US but maybe I'd be working as like a
bodyguard or like a security guard or
something I wouldn't have had maybe the
same success that I did if I hadn't
taken this insane Journey
um but his thing is that like he's been
very vocal about how like UFC contracts
aren't fair and like things like that
and I'm like okay well and he's like I
don't uh my identity is not tied to
being MMA champion and I'm like who are
you then like what does that mean and
he's like there will there have been
many before me and there will be many
after me this is not who makes me me
what makes me me is that I have the
ability to to reinvent and I have that
skill set and he's like very talented
people are just really afraid of
starting over and that's why they grip
so tightly to what they already have is
because they're scared from starting to
start from zero again so who knows what
his next chapter is but the beauty I
think in his thinking is like
I am not these external accolades I am
Francis and I can be whatever I want to
be regardless of like what Society tries
to slap on me yeah there's a line as
well you've got that says embody the
version of yourself you want to be very
petersonian uh approach there I think
but it's so it's so so lovely and um you
know one of the themes I guess that
we've spoken about today is this
this line between confidence competence
delusion positive thinking realism
fantasy trying to sort of work all of
this into a big a big blob and showing
up
in the way that you would do and like a
question I've got this written on my
fridge I've got this written on the
front of my fridge and it's been on
there for like four months now and it
says what would you tomorrow want you
today to do
exactly and like I me tomorrow would
want me to get up on time to train hard
to high five with the boys after we
complete a grueling 45 minute workout to
not go and spend time on my phone once
we finish this podcast but to go for a
walk like that's what me tomorrow would
want me today to do and that's embodying
the version of myself that I want to be
yeah it's like living like your
aspirational self and
um and I think like here's the thing
like I think the way you bridge what you
said you're like the cynicism with the
positivity is not to go all in to like
manifesting and like positive thinking
although like you know a lot of athletes
say like they do positive visualization
which is like they they focus and they
visualize themselves like making the
play and being the thing and doing the
thing but actually what a lot of people
I've interviewed have told me including
uh this Olympic swimmer is that what
they end up doing when they're like
standing there on the blocks I think
that's what it's called at the Olympics
about to dive in actually what's more
powerful than like positive
visualization is looking at the past and
like playing a mental movie of every
where you've been how far you fell how
how much you failed and like what you
had to overcome that led you to this
moment right here and I think like
that's so powerful because that gives
you real confidence versus something you
haven't achieved yet
oh yeah Paulina I really appreciate you
you've got new book you've got
newsletter you've got other things where
should people go if they want to check
out your stuff online thank you Chris
for my newsletter it's
readtheprofile.com and for the book it's
hiddengeniusfuck.com if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe